- Hey guys, it's me
Gary Vaynerchuk.
The reason I am making this
video or I don't know if DRock
audio-ing it is because
DRock missed his flight.
And had DRock not missed his
flight we wouldn't have audio
issues, we would not have
episode 24 coming out when
episode 32 is coming out.
It wouldn't be a clusterfuck but
it was and that's what happened.
DRock's inexperienced with his
traveling, he thought that he
could have his ticket on his app
but when you fly internationally
you need to print it out.
He didn't understand that and
even though he taxied for quite
a while in LA he still had
plenty of time to make the
flight, unfortunately though
his inexperience cost him.
And inexperience is
dangerous at times.
(light music)
So just slept for about
10 hours and did about
four hours of work on my email.
Caught up with a bunch of you.
DRock missed his flight but was
hustling and found somebody to
record while I'm in
Australia so that will be fun.
We're about to land in Sydney.
I'm excited to get into my day.
In and out, land, go to the
hotel, shower, meeting,
go to the event and go
back to the airport. Hustle.
Is the last name
Vaynerchuk for you?
- That's me.
- [Gary] Vaynerchuk?
- Right here.
- [Gary] That's me.
I felt it.
- You felt it?
- [Gary] I felt it.
(light music)
So many people in
this room and live their lives
one way but they market a
completely different way. Right?
One of the things that bothers
me the most, especially the
whole market, you know, these 21
hour traveling days allow you to
catch up on a lot of work.
And on the way here I paid
attention to a lot of the people
in this room that have been
tweeting or Facebooking or
emailing me that they were going
to be here and I took advantage
and was able to do three or four
hours of research to really pay
attention to what some of you
guys are doing in this room.
And to be very honest with you
and I apologize I didn't want
to come to Sydney to razz but
to be very honest with you
the far majority of
people in this room
that are marketing are marketing
in their best interest and
not in their consumer's
best interest.
The lack of patience, the lack
of content that has anything to
do with that other than what
you want them to do is quite
stunning and would be a very
quick indicator to me that the
return on the investment is not
as great as you'd like it to be
because default into
caring about yourself first.
A lot of you have consumed my
stuff, you've heard my spiel.
I'm a big believer that the
people that win deploy more
value than they
ask for in return.
That entire fucking business is
built on telling people how to
fix think they suck at
when they can't maximize it.
That's the truth.
Way too many
people can't get there.
It is against everything
you hear from everybody.
I get it.
I understand how I sit on this
island very by myself in the
ecosystem but fuck man let
me say this; Think about 1000
people that are the most famous
and successful in the world and
they all have only
one thing in common.
They fucking punted everything
besides that one talent and
spent every fucking minute in
their lives on that one talent.
What the disconnect is is
that people want something to be
happening or don't want
something to be happening versus
respecting what's happening.
People don't want to
learn to Snapchat.
It's another thing to learn.
- Yeah.
- They don't want to learn.
And it's confusing
compared to the others.
- (inaudible)
- Probably and so
that's what I do.
I'm completely unemotional.
It just is what it is.
Ready?
- Ready.
- Ready, set, go.
- [Gary] First of all I could
wish anything for anybody it
would be health to them and
their family if I could wish the
second thing it would be
self-awareness because it is the
prerequisite to a lot of
happiness but third would be for
you guys to even feel for 15
seconds what it feels like for
people to want to take
your selfie with you or
have you sign a book.
My mom coddled me a lot as a kid
and give me a lot of compliments
and I really truly believe that
I live a public life because
I want to replicate that love
feeling and that's what you guys
did for me today and so I'll
fly anywhere for 21 hours to get
this kind of vibe back.
(light music)